snitch on the toast a snitch on the
toast Smee chest on the garlic bread
speeches on the garlic bread
welcome to the show counselor Smee
[Music]
everyone is so excited that America's
favorite counselor and Italy's favorite
council she's worldwide has joined us on
the show today
good morning Millennials good morning
counselor
thank you I needed that how are you
doing good I'm I'm very tired you know
waking up early it's not really my thing
I know but you do it for the love of the
campers I drew the love of the campers
and I've been waking up early earlier
than normal for the past month so like I
was think I should be used to it by now
but I'm just on knowyou net by the way
you never get used to really ya know
what I was thinking about like most
people I was actually thinking about
this this morning most people like have
to wake up early right it's like why
wasn't it just an inherent thing that
it's not hard here some just like I'm
taking us in for water is it hard no
it's like they people wake up yeah
waking up is hard but then they get over
it like I never get over notice why he's
tired a thing if that just shouldn't be
do you don't I mean I'm just saying it's
biologically being tired shouldn't be a
thing that's just what I think but oh I
don't know maybe it should you have to
listen to your body counselor snitch
it's so important well my body's always
telling me that I'm tired so just I
should have moved forever
I don't know counselor this is above my
pay grade as a six year old camper who's
just trying on a doctor almost jealous
yeah who's just trying to be your
favorite camper you are my favorite
camper thank you I mean I really feel so
bad for the American camp for these days
because I'm I thought she hasn't been
shown up no it's like she's really just
been so overshadowed by the Italian
camper like everyone loves the Italian
camper and everyone thinks American
campers so annoying but it's like
American camper has such a good heart I
don't think that she's annoying but she
just hasn't been showing up lately she's
been completely overshadowed by Italian
camera okay she needs to show up but I
think she's been a little discouraged
what do you want me to do I know you
need to get in there and have a bunk
meeting Oh God
just a fish by two campers well I don't
know I think we're gonna be introducing
some some some new campers this summer
oh I'm scared
yeah I didn't seeing some applications
oh no from my countries France oh it's
exciting
it's an exciting time to be a camper in
counselors snitches bunk and it's an
exciting time to be on the morning toast
so if you're done complaining welcome to
the show
yes the morning complaints are over so
what else is new with you you've been
really busy I've been really busy
um what's new with me nothing well we
just got off well I just got off of a
crazy like of the dirty jeans tour
Claudia is still on it but I just could
not bear to miss another week of school
so we've just been you know hitting I
think we were in like six states cause
like you know Connecticut counts yeah
and it was just a lot but I'm very happy
to be home even though it's for a week
and a half because that we are off to
Florida but yeah you know just being a
jetsetter rocker mario's owed the shows
at Orlando very fun very fun how is
spring break so nice we very pick and
chose when we wanted to you know joins
the spread like what what is the correct
word pick and choose pick and choose but
like it was a nice pass we very much
picked and chose editor whatever
whatever when we wanted to be part of
the Spring Breakers so we got to like
chill a lot and then you know I also
drink bit but it was so nice to relax
and just you know really listen to my
body were you tired there count always
but like not as much because I slept in
and then like just chilled so that was
nice understood we have a lot of
questions for you about your jobs your
status as a student your counts whether
or not I am still in your counseling
abilities but we'll get to that at the
end of the show okay
yes now it is time to deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay first up in
the developing story of Jesse smell ed
so yesterday right before we went live
it came out that all charges against
Jesse smell like had been dropped which
to me is just the presumption of
innocence you know like we were dropped
because he's innocent right
turns out that that's not necessarily
the case though everyone is innocent
until proven guilty that that would also
hold true for his alleged assailants
right so this is a very messy story
still it did he alleged assailant still
in prison I don't think so I think
everyone everyone went home hmm okay
which is quite interesting so yesterday
all we knew that the charges were
dropped so to me that means an innocent
man there was no evidence that's that's
what that means to me yes
as evidence the state's attorney says
quote I do not believe he is innocent
jussie Smollett the prosecutor who
dropped charges against Jessie Smollett
said Tuesday that doesn't mean he is not
guilty of staging a hate crime against
himself and he attributed the move in
part to the actor's lack of criminal
history quote I do not believe he is
innocent First Assistant Cook County
State's Attorney Joseph maggots who took
over the case after Kim Cox recused
herself told a Chicago CBS affiliate she
lied should recuse herself I don't know
she must have had like a conflict of
interest on Empire maybe quote based on
all facts and circumstances of the case
and also keeping in mind resources and
keeping in mind that the offices
number-one priority is to combat violent
crime and the drivers of violence I
decided to offer this disposition in the
case maggots told the outlet he said
smell let's clean criminal record was a
factor according to multiple multiple
reports maggots also insisted that he
made the call to drop the charges and
said Fox didn't have anything to do with
the decision maggots also denied Mayor
Rahm Emmanuel's claim that the decision
was quote a whitewash of justice
essentially accusing Smollett of
preferential treatment due to his
celebrity quote not true it's just not
he said it's not a whitewash he did he
did community service he has forfeited
his bond it's just not a whitewash okay
his bond was $10,000 so he did he paid
ten thousand dollars and he did 16 hours
of community service at Reverend Jesse
Jackson's Human Rights Coalition and 15
hours and voila
yeah 16 hours I don't know something
right something's not right and it's so
crazy that everyone in the political
field in Chicago is not agreeing on it
like Breyer is not agreeing with the
state's attorney oh and I just think
that if this decision were to be me like
everyone was supposed to be on board
right who made this just like this is
the guy the DA me no but like someone
definitely made him make this oh yes oh
my god like definitely some not
pay-for-play excited oh he was paid but
you know there's definitely some we
strong words for play charades
but you would think those showing words
they could be coming from the mayor but
it's not the mayor so so it's higher up
I don't like it I don't know and I'm
just I'm so confused and so the the
rationale is that he's not a threat to
society so let's let him back on the
streets we'd remember Lee not which
makes a lot of sense yeah who's a threat
to himself but plenty of people who
commit crimes aren't a threat to society
right Laurie Lachlan is not a threat to
society
Lachlan it's Lachlan what yeah just take
a minute to group to realize that wait
but it's am I losing my mind
why Laurie well it spelled Laughlin but
it's pronounced Lachlan but it's a G but
an H but it's pronounced Lachlan Wow Wow
you really learn something new every day
that's what we do here on the morning
shows we educate how'd you even figure
that out um I was watching a report
about her or reporter was no and they
said Laughlin pronounced Lachlan like
they were answering everyone's questions
then I also read that the FBI is still
investigating him and so was the US
postal service because of like the hate
mail but he received mail fraud same
thing with Laurie Lachlan that every day
everything everyone on mail fraud if you
mail something that's not legitimate
it's mail fraud is that right yeah which
is so crazy and it's likewise - email -
we were just talking about this
yesterday I won't everything is mail
fraud and that's how they get you
yeah you are mail fraud they could get
just e mail fraud because of that hate
letter yeah interesting but I don't know
I don't see it happening like is the big
this is a big you know what the thing is
it's like in all of these things these
documentaries we watch there's always
those trials but they always go the
wrong way and it's like is that
happening now or are we gonna be
watching the documentary about this in
20 years I don't know and then if you
hear from Jesse and we've read his
boyars statement yesterday like he's
maintaining his innocence in all of this
right well he kind of has to right now
no but so it's like it's really now now
that there's not gonna be a case there's
not gonna be any evidence shown it's
just who do you believe when you say
he's maintaining his innocence he's
saying that shoot like that three people
assaulted him uh-huh
hmm that he was the victim hmm
hmm I don't know actually there so I'm
just keeping up reading on it I feel
like we keep finding out new stuff and
it's just it's so musty at the Cook
County State's Attorney's Office and I
think they need to clean it up
yeah they kick a broom they need to
clean up the mus the must and the fuss
you know because I I can't keep up keep
up and it's just like and honestly it's
so funny that like this is all going
down about Jesse Similac because when I
was watching Empire million years ago
did you like his character yeah I loved
his character he always had the best
songs yes I remember you and Olivia
listening to it and it was a terrible
song and now like five years later this
is happening it's a crazy thing it's the
craziest thing
and just like Empire know I like fell
off wood this whole situation make you
want to watch it more or less um
I'm indifferent like I just like I don't
really care anymore about the show I was
watching and I'll just got started to
get too complicated and I was just over
it like I wanted to invest my time in
other shows like you know dynasty like
dynasty it kind of is like dynasty it's
about you know Empire dynasty synonyms
dynasty is so good you guys I don't know
if all of you watch China see we've
really shelled for it as much as we
possibly shopping more I could if you're
not watching right now like you're not
living your life to the fullest it is
the greatest show on TV I'm Lynne truss
and Sylvester was here yesterday he
asked me like up and he was like what
scripted what's your favorite scripted
show and I was like dynasty and he was
shook to the corgis watching yes oh and
it's like no one like it's so underrated
it's so underrated my biggest fear is it
being 200 that it gets canceled and then
I will just be upset I know like but it
does have a season three so we have a
whole other season to push it on you
guys and like we shouldn't even have to
also we could talk about like what's
going on in Riverdale um I we can't
because I'm so behind oh you are yeah
I'm like because I've been away for the
past month I haven't been able to keep
up on my shows but I just have to say
that the Heather's episode please don't
so he was bad was cringe
oh because Cole Sprouse saying no he
wasn't even that bad the whole thing
like it was just uh it was not for me
okay they always choose like random
musicals and then it was Heather's even
a musical yeah oh I just remember the
movie yeah it was a musical I think Liz
Gillies might have been in it oh my god
I'll just do like Mean Girls it all
comes back to dynasty or Legally Blonde
everyone wants a shot of my boots and
you know what because I love them so
much this is my first time wearing them
I'm gonna pick my leg up for you do it
they are by Malone sue Lee airs
I think the French hamper brought them
as a gift to curry favor with the
counselor sister yes and I [ __ ] love
them they're like have a little cowboy
player they're elegant they're very what
a little song about me I don't have a
comment they're saying that you're the
best counselor in the whole world that's
a lie no it's not you've gotten me
through some really tough times
counselor that's true I have through
your counseling yes so the boots are
like really crazy and fun so I tried to
say keep it low-key with the outfit
today but I really think they're gonna
be like a fun summer boot with Eugene
short oh so cute so cute
so you're looking so cute today snatch
Jake use your outfit bye
okay well um this is off-white ever
heard of it and then Virgil yeah
Virgil AB they're just seizing these new
boots that I'm currently obsessed with
are Maison Margiela and these jeans are
top shop are they dirty these jeans oh
yeah I never wash these jeans because
they get so tight so they're dirty jeans
five days in a row get over it
the amount of times that I've heard that
line yeah it never gets old for me but I
haven't heard it as much as you okay are
you ready for our next story yeah hit me
in another developing story from
yesterday that is just taking a turn for
the worst quote drunk Wendy Williams
rushed to hospital after husband's
alleged mistress has baby
devastated Wendy Williams is not in a
good way after being rushed to the
hospital hours after her husband's
alleged mistress gave birth the
talk-show host was found drunk on Monday
soon after page six reported that Serena
Hudson the alleged longtime love of her
husband Kevin hunter had given birth she
was taken to the hospital where she was
given IV fluids however she still showed
to the set of her show and filmed on
Tuesday the star had left the sober home
in Queens where she has been staying
sparking a hunt for her before she was
found
but she's now back at the
facility we're told it's widely believed
that hunter is the father of Hudson's
baby and a source said Wendy is not in a
good way everyone is so concerned for
her the sad thing is that she's been
working so hard to stay sober and she's
been so honest and her struggles with
all her fans and this just skipped her
over the edge
okay so I think it's very obvious that
you know one thing has to do with the
other officer just and I were saying
yesterday perhaps she went back to being
drinking and being a bad place because
she found out that her husband was
having a baby with someone else oh yeah
in general yeah like back a few months
ago right when she went away and didn't
do her show but now it's like this
shouldn't be if that's true then this
shouldn't be news to her right um but I
just like hitting her harder I don't
know that is so sad are they still
together her and the husband technically
yeah mmm and he like works with her I
think he's like her manager and messy
messy messy and she's just such a great
woman and obviously we all know that she
deserves so much better and I just I
just want her I want to know that for
her sighs yeah you know that's really
sad I feel really bad for her
but you've got I'd go through the storm
to get to the rainbow because the rain
and wind stop blowing but you're stuck
out in the same old storm again we just
harmonized yeah love it so hold tight to
your umbrella darling I'm just trying to
tell you that there's always been a remo
hang it over
it'll OB alright this is neither part of
the song this is easily like so
beautiful like a little nursery for
everyone to listen to or like maybe so
many for the two other sisters who
cannot sing right but I think together
we make each other better I don't know
um that's a nice sentiment I love that
song obviously in the message and it's
really true and I hope that Wendy really
like find some joy and happiness and
stability after this man I can't even
deal with him but he is her husband so
you like don't want to talk too much
[ __ ] you know cuz if you respect Wendy
you've got a respect right choices right
right but it's not a very good choice
because he's clearly a bad man honestly
he is or as Jess and I were saying
yesterday you might have like an open a
Hollywood open relationship situation
but in which put us at work issues like
this wouldn't drive you right to be
drinking so I don't know I just like
feel for her I love her
whatever she needs and I just can't
believe she's still doing her show at
this tough time like is she gonna be on
how often is she on every day every day
but I think they do some pre-taped so oh
my god that is that is crazy people are
liking the case you do it ooh maybe
Willa are we the next Maddie and Tay
perhaps how was the concert last night
oh my god I can't believe it's taken me
this long just bring up blood and Stella
the concert was amazing i bob lennon
says so much if you don't know who she
is she was on nashville her and running
and Maisie the little twins who got fit
you miss like from you know the cops
pick up so now she went solo and her
music is so good and she's so good and
she's so pretty like mmm so pretty and
I'm just like really obsessed with her
and I just need her like I feel like
she's gonna be like the next Kacey
Musgraves like achieved they very much
have that vibe of like sad songs you
know she was so good like I can't talk
about her enough she's just such good
music takes a [ __ ] know a [ __ ] yeah it
does really does take a [ __ ] no [ __ ]
you know yeah that seems to be a song
that speaks to you particular know it's
very relatable takes a snitch to now a
snitch I don't know how to make them up
with that takes a snitch knows like I
feel like you don't appreciate her as
much as I do no I do beg her to come
with us last night
no I no avail well I just didn't have
any energy yesterday and I don't have a
lot today but I'm working on it yeah
it's just hard you know counts I know um
what was I gonna say about run and
Stella and Stella
her dog Oh named ocean by the way King
Charles Cavalier sighing she has a Theo
named ocean really cute one too it's
really cute named ocean and she brings
him ocean I don't know everywhere and
like on tour bus just like Cupid they
got him a little like tour like pass I
know and it's like now is the time cuz
she's not huge yet yeah I know I've been
then she'll watch this episode were you
like plotted to be her friend right but
your intentions are pure my intentions
are pure I really think we'd have like a
great time together okay I'm like we're
the same age
yeah I think she might be your younger
but still cool cool she's so cool
very cool I'm excited for you for my new
budding friendship but she doesn't know
about yet yeah okay this next story is
really crazy and I'm all over the map
about how I feel about it
cardi B says she drugged and robbed men
because she had quote limited options
after a video surfaced of cardi B
admitting to robbing and drugging men
the singer is explaining herself in the
clip from an Instagram Live recorded
three years ago the rapper said quote I
had to go strip I had to go oh yeah you
want to [ __ ] me yeah yeah yeah let's go
back to this hotel and I drugged them up
and I robbed them that's what I used to
do be a hip hot ratchet she explained
after horrified social media users
responded to the 26 year old stars
confession with the hashtag surviving
cardi B in reference to surviving our
Kelly
cardi took to Instagram to explain her
actions quote so I'm seeing on social
media that an Instagram live I did three
years ago has popped back up a live
where I talked about things I had to do
in my past right or wrong that I felt I
needed to do to make a living she wrote
in a post on Tuesday I never claimed to
be perfect or come from a perfect world
with a perfect pass I always speak my
truth I always on my [ __ ] the star said
that while many artists glorify violence
and crime that was never her style
there are rappers that glorify murder
violence drugs and robbing crimes they
feel they had to do to survive I never
glorified the things I brought up in
that live I never even put those things
in my music because I'm not proud of it
and feel responsibility not to glorify
it well the former stripper said she was
not proud of her actions she felt they
were necessary at the time quote I made
the choices that I did at the time
because I had very limited options I was
blessed to have been able to rise from
that but so many women have not she said
whether or not they were poor choices at
the time I did what I had to do to
survive okay yeah so in first I read
this and I guess every time I like read
a news article on the internet I just
never think it's a a big like I never
registered the gravitas of it big or
small totally okay yes so when I first
read an old live surfaced it was also
coupled with her statement so I was like
okay she said this and the live and then
here's her statement where she said I
did what I had to do and I just didn't
even process what it was that she had to
do yes then I saw all these comments and
the toasters where it was like could you
imagine if a man did this if this was a
man Oh canceled Anish like it is a real
crime and like a horrible thing that
like it's a Bill Cosby you know and I
also happen to be watching an episode of
American greed last night where it's
about these girls who work in a bar who
like bring back rich men and drugged
them and then swipe their credit card
like over and over again um and they
wound up working for like a bigger
Russian mob and I a me but like that's
what like that's how they made money and
so it's it's a serious crime enough to
be on American greed and cardi B is out
here doing and admitting it and then
it's like in her statement she did ever
she she says I did what I had to do to
survive which sort of like minimizes
what it was that she was doing like I
don't I think they're what I really
don't know what to think here like it
was odd like it's very very [ __ ] up
it's very [ __ ] up but it's also cardi
B and like we love her and everyone
loves her and like she said never knows
that she like has these like weird
things about her but then it's like when
it comes down to it like this is a
criminal acts ain't cool like but it's
like to so many people she can do no
wrong and like I feel like I am one of
those people who want to stop and think
about I'm like no this is very wrong
yeah exactly it's like I want to defend
her
but like I can't write like it's a day
right no and you just have to think like
if it were a man oh my god
in this situation like it would be over
for that there was an FBI would be
looking into it this ain't right the
same rules like have to apply for
everyone and as much as we love her they
have to apply for cardi B and like I
just I think like she'll be fine and I
think people love her so much that like
this is also a part of her story it's
not like coming out of a field right
she's never pretend to be someone that
she's not like she's always been honest
with her fans so I think she'll be fine
it's just like really shocking really
shocking and that's all I have to say
that is like I haven't all I've see like
no one is like what I've read I don't
really know other than the hashtag like
surviving cardi B which is also still
making a joke of it like it's still a
joke like no one's really know I haven't
seen any media or watch any shows where
people are really talking about it how
seriously we're gonna decide to take
this right right no just like it's just
like a story do you already mean yeah
it's not like I don't know it's the way
it's being him I don't know what to say
cuz it's just like it's just so shocking
like and it just doesn't really seem
like real or that people are taking it
as real things that she like robbed and
drugs men like that's nuts that's nuts
and especially cuz I was literally just
watching that episode I'm like wow this
is a horrible horrible thing for women
to do to men who just like we're just
like for a good time yeah yeah well in
the in the American group they were just
looking for a good time it's like this
weatherman who went down to Miami
like cuz he it was right after like the
February sweeps of weather and like he
had the week off and he loves to go in
Miami and he's single and he's cute and
he goes to a bar and he's to women
approach him and they're like let's go
to the like they're drinking Pinot
Grigio with him and they like persuade
him to take a shot he was like no I
don't 1 2 and finally they literally
throw it down the hatch and it's drugged
and the whole rest of the night is a
blur
that's so sighs a piece of art in an
auction that turned out to be just like
a piece of art on the wall at the bar
that they worked and in total in two
nights and then they left his wallet in
the room they didn't he didn't know that
he had robbed probably else and there
was no money 11 doesn't make that much
money I think he's thinking was doing
okay because they in total in two nights
he they got $40,000 out of him and
that's like his salary yeah and then
American Express like what
money-back wouldn't give him the money
back but then Miami Vice like didn't
undercover investigation like they were
doing this like a bunch of men I don't
know but he's on American green now so I
think that's doing fine yeah I think
that's also justice you know till the
end to see the gang taken down know for
sure that's totally justice yeah so
anyways I was just watching this and now
it's life imitates art you know what
else I was watching American greed last
night and I love American Dream but it
also always puts me to sleep that's why
I like it but I still like it um you
know Martin shkreli the pharmaceutical
guy he was like the most hated man in
America
no the only pharmaceutical nut guy I
know is George from Desperate Housewives
me too up until last night anyways I was
started watching his because I never
really understood what he did I never
paid a ticket or II he is like an evil
troll oh and he was making money in the
stock market but then losing it and he
wound up buying of a drug like a
medicine that is used for probably
predominantly AIDS patients pregnant
women and babies like when they have
like they'll have a um something where
they need this drug and he raised the
price from $13 for a pill to seven
hundred and fifty dollars for one pill
how can he do that because he don't like
it was just crazy but he's now he's on
trial for securities fraud so you know
at all roots it's like you know OJ not
mail fraud not now uh no no maybe it's
always mail fraud it's but it's like OJ
going to jail for memorabilia really
yeah they always got you on that with
those they always get you even when you
run away um anyways we'll update you on
this cardi B story and if there's any
fallout from him I just I wouldn't be
surprised if there is and I also want to
be surprised there isn't me to because
it's like it's this isn't such a
departure from who she's always said
that she is which is like someone who
does what she needs to do in order to
survive that's true and that's all
that's all she wrote that's all Joey
okay next story a little salacious celeb
hookup Stephanie Pratt and dark paths
date night may have just sparked a new
relationship someone needs to check on
Claudia oh my god I didn't even think
about her
Wow
I guess I just I thought she was so past
it you know it just shows how much she's
grown since their DMS back in the day
right right she's gonna kill us yeah
everything is coming up roses for
Stephanie Pratt in the hills of Southern
California with excitement building for
the hills new beginnings okay I want to
get back to that false statement in a
second one of the show's returning cast
members decided to go on a date with a
fellow reality star anyone remember
Derek Pett from The Bachelorette yeah
horse but it's anyone remember Stephanie
Pratt thank you thank you the pyramid up
earlier this month in LA and while
things may have started off a little
rocky a second date may be on the agenda
quota took an hour and 15 minutes before
Steph finally showed up and her
reasoning is she was in Hawaii and they
don't have daylight savings time and she
never changed her clock and she thought
it was a different time
Derek shared on I heart radios Pratt
cast podcast probably the third thing I
said to her was you need to pick out
food because the kitchen closes in ten
minutes according to Derek he's never
watch the hills I knew nothing about
Stephanie other than her brother
his name's Spencer Pratt and while he
predicted she would be a true Southern
Cali girl with no interest in being on
the date Derek admitted that the evening
was pretty darn sweet I was pleasantly
surprised she's a lot smarter than I
thought and very quick he told wells
Adams there was not an empty dull moment
he continued we went to two Irish bars
we met a couple and barhop with them for
two hours I'm into it I would definitely
see her again so it's fun do you make
out was involved before the night was
over and as for the second date the odds
are in Derek's favor she suggested I
stay longer I think would it be cool to
do New York oh I guess the the the date
was in New York I don't know I was in
Hawaii
oh she was anyway we're confusing
anyways this is so cute I just love when
people find each other and it's really
giving me um Nikki Bella and Peter
Krause vibes oh you watch that and no
but she's with her Dancing with the
Stars partner yeah so why does it matter
because they they're meant for each
other
oh and she did and the problem was the
timing because she wasn't over John Cena
and she couldn't even kiss him because
like she hadn't kissed someone else in
five years like she was still so raw
from it and you know she definitely see
at our time out of her system or maybe
like they're meant for each other
either way is great but like I think
Peter really likes her or they're just
the best actors in the whole world
maybe honestly no I I feel like he would
really like her like she's into fitness
and all that anyway when he came on the
show he said he was interested in a
brunette
wasn't on The Bachelor and at the time
you thought it was Claudia but I think
it's Nikki Bella shucks that's actually
really cute well I just want to I've got
to be happy and like me Tim coming from
where he went was Tomoka like yeah wow
that is anyone would be better um well I
want this is a curious story to me
because the hills new beginnings is
coming back it's unclear when because
they're it's mushy as hell they're -
it's mushy as hell so they first did an
interview where it said it was coming
back in April that's next month then it
said it was coming to summer then I read
yesterday that they're doing reshoots
because I guess they didn't get the cut
because inherently spend it's like this
isn't a Martin Scorsese film like this
is just supposed to be like a fun
reality TV show that yes is a little
scripted we know that about the hills
but like it's not you know the greatest
artistry of our time I don't understand
why why they are having such difficulty
Pratt like kind of alluded to on his
podcast not that I listen but I read
somewhere that um a lot of people are
like not addressing issues on camera
doing stuff like that because they want
they want to protect their image so
people are afraid to like be involved in
drama or have drama because they don't
want like people to hate them but it's
like then why are you going on a reality
show right this is the inherent problem
with the show because either it needs to
be a reality show which it's not because
we know that the hills is scripted and
they're proud to be like a scripted
reality type show or you need people
acting in which case bring back the OSI
and Mischa Barton could get back to work
yeah well actually Mischa Barton is only
one who's really equipped for the job on
the hills but go simmer hisses pass and
Love Actually I just have to say like I
think the hills new beginnings is a
horrible idea I wasn't into it that I'm
not into it now like just give Spencer
and Heidi a reality show and we'll be
set okay no they're not afraid to air
their drama on TV and I and like all of
these people are so image conscious like
Whitney port like she has like
squeaky-clean image what is she gonna do
on the show that's gonna be remotely
interesting totally same with Audrina
and her brand deals but yeah she [ __ ]
did a sponsored pregnancy announcement
like I don't think she's gonna be doing
anything that would make any of the
brands that she works with look like and
you are bad I want to know I want to
know how like the people who are putting
together the
this hills new beginning like didn't
think of this no because they're just so
caught up in the thirst and like
everyone and it's their job not to be no
it's their jobs like our I mean this is
just what so backwards about Holly
wouldn't like they just think any
because they can't find success with new
shows they think a reboot is the answer
to everything if it had success then
it's gonna have success now and like
you're barely seeing that with Jersey
Shore like can't we just barely yeah
that's so true Jack II can we just move
on apparently not because maybe they
can't even come up with good ideas for
new shows so they have to go back to the
old and it's just like why like it's
called
growth you know like Kristin Cavallari
has grown yes and like she went from the
hills and now she's back on TV and like
I love her show you do and it's exactly
what she should be doing yes and she
doesn't show her kids on it so it's like
there are things about it that aren't
like so great because it's really it's
kind of like a Vanderpump rules style
with the workers but the people that
work for her are like so immature and so
like such babies and it's annoying and
it's like it's it's really annoying
um and then she like hangs out with her
friend and like tells her friend what
happened at work it's like we were all
just saw it and it wasn't that
interesting to begin with so now we have
to hear the recap and she's gonna tell
Jay but her and her husband are like so
cute and husband is so cute they're so
real and he's hilarious
and he actually gives like some pretty
good advice and I like I like where it's
headed I think it could be more like
Nashville getting into the lives of the
people who work there but they tried
that last season and people weren't into
it people weren't into it the cast got
too big of heads and they also set up
some work for her needs people to work
for her so like I think she was like I
don't I don't want you filming them
anymore because they're like getting
carried away like one girl like who was
her social media manager then like I was
yeah never showed she's on my explore
page every day she's like I don't even
follow her I don't even know watch a
show but I know her name's not informed
she got like a little taste of fame from
the show and then like never showed up
to work again fired okay good um so yeah
I think there's a better way to do the
hills new beginnings or you know what
what about the hills and just a
completely new cast like I could think
of tons of groups and young Hollywood
that I would love to for you to follow
totally and that I don't know about that
that I don't know about yet I
be introduced to new people like how I
was introduced to Juliet Porter right
look I want new people to follow that's
what they should have done is the hills
new beginnings and it's an all-new cast
who's 21 years old yeah and they're on
the one hand they have a little bit of a
name for themselves but they do want
more Instagram followers therefore they
will do what it takes to make the show a
success
toast news network will have a reality
side and will make that happen cuz
clearly nobody else can right
or you get the cast members grown up
Spencer and Heidi and their lives and
like that's interesting too yeah that is
but either right honestly I won't be
watching or you put it on Real
Housewives of Orange County which was a
rumor that happened once and I'm so here
for it Mary no I think she is no she's
not remember than she started dating oh
right Cabrera so no she's not it was
okay so it was a rumor that started when
she was married but also no one I know
how that is actually married anymore
oh that's true I actually don't think
one person an Orange County no uh
Tamra's married and the new girls are
getting one is anybody from New York
married um one right not one that's nuts
yeah but I think that's the point now
you know it's like I don't think they
would even do a woman like these women
are just such independent like forces
that that's the show okay you know we
are some Beverly Hills they're all
married interesting but it's also this
it's still a great it like New York
America Hills are still so good and has
nothing to do with them being married or
no no no it's just also just called Real
Housewives full of interesting factoids
that are well interesting our fifth and
final story Justin Bieber is taking a
break from music to focus on his mental
health Justin Bieber this was not the
story that I thought I chose this story
that admits sorry I must have clicked
something else Justin Bieber admits that
he still loves Selena Gomez you know the
headline and if God's the headline
headline that's the headline oh my god
Wow I'm mad for him Justin Bieber is
being tested this week hours after
announcing he was taking a break from
music to focus on deeper issues the
singer exploded after an Instagram troll
went after his wife Haley Baldwin the
haters comment read you are not in love
with Haley you only married her to get
back at Selena Plus Haley sleeps with
men like Shawn Mendes her theme and
she's a racist
instead of turning the other cheek the
enraged sorry singer wrote back
defending his wife and addressing his
relationship with his ex quote a logical
person doesn't talk or think this way
you should be ashamed of yourself really
I always I absolutely loved and loved
Selena she will always hold a place in
my heart but I am head over heels in
love with my wife and she is absolutely
the best thing that has ever happened to
me period he also addressed the constant
barrage of hateful comments that he
involved and received quote this is
reply to all the immature sick people
who send Haley hurtful messages like he
always goes back to Selena or Selena is
better for him he ranted you have no
idea of my life and what's good for me
Haley is my bride period if you don't
like that or support that that means you
don't support me you're not a fan or a
good person if you were raised right
your parents would have said if you
don't have something nice to say don't
say anything
Bieber then posted a screenshot up the
comment to his Instagram saying stop
sending Haley and I these messages if
you love me screenshot this and repost
this everywhere and if you love me
please talk about it on the mornin toes
because I know you were maybe weren't
going to especially not yesterday and
today I kind of glazed over it but then
Margo suggested we talk about it is
hurting Gemma graphic and you know I
don't dislike Choson Ebersol helps
spread the message okay any like if you
put all of that in his insert Wow I know
I read that also and I like Haley ball
because she has good style of Haley
Baldwin like so much we're like I love
him and her and Justin Bieber like so
much like really it makes so much sense
to me I think that they're perfect
together and maybe I'm not even maybe
I'm wrong so be it I don't care the fact
Lee the headline was that he messy sale
of Selena Gomez makes me so mad and you
know what like there was a post about
this in the toasters and someone
comments it like I just wish he hadn't
had to Ted Selena's name because now the
headline would be like he admits 11
Selena Gomez like no way look he said so
many other things she was right I feel
like I don't care about these people I
and I don't know why and I think it's
about like the Selena Gomez of it all
and I know that she hasn't been trying
it from the show but I just really want
her to like I really don't like talking
about her because I feel like anytime
she's in the news it's like so
manufactured and it's not what she's
actually doing so like what's the point
I feel and then when it comes to Justin
and Haley I I feel like we know nothing
about them to like and I think that they
are good for each other
they're I don't know that they're
perfect and that they're in such a great
place because I never said I've seen him
like
they're in a great place but you know
marriage is hard work right but I think
I know that they're really they're doing
the thing you know like they're they're
married they're living together they're
you stay you know they're doing ani like
that's what all you can ask of a couple
like and they're just trying and
everyone like is just [ __ ] on them
and it's like leave him alone and like
Selena Gomez it just doesn't do for me I
just don't like her I just like I don't
care about her and I feel like I
literally don't know anything about her
I see her coat adds her Puma adds that's
about it yeah yeah I so anytime he has
to do it to when the headline is he
still of Selena for that reason I'm out
I've see that headline a hundred times
but like that's not what this year's
been what's good for him is like I
actually don't even really associate him
with Selena Gomez anymore
me neither he's really like and who
would have ever thought that that was
possible considering they were attached
for so long but even when they weren't
together but like now I really see him
and like Haley Baldwin that like he's
her she's his girl you know she really
is but they Haley and him had just as
big of a history as selena and Justin
but nobody really cared that's the thing
because he Anna was huge in Haley
Baldwin really wasn't at the time yeah
it's just so it's like a friend of
kendall Jenner right which is you know a
good place to be yeah but whatever so
that's that I like them I only honestly
wish good things for them and I really
would love some new Justin Bieber music
yeah do you think it's coming um he
alluded that I think he it's coming like
not soon but it's coming yeah I've
actually got an album from him and so on
its purpose which was actually so good
so men
that'll be exciting for you what new
music are you enjoying councilors Mitch
what school ooh
London's dela if you've ever heard of
her what else am i listening to I've
been listening to Matty and tie a lot
lately they've been having some good new
music I've weirdly been listening to
George Strait a lot weirdly he's been
putting out new music you know he's a
king that's what they call him the king
okay he's been putting out country new
music and he has one called God in
country music with his little
five-year-old nephew and it's so cute
and he sings on it and it's just really
cute and then he has he just came out
one which is my personal favorite right
now which is called the weight of the
badge it's just about like police
officers and what they like sacrificed
to do their job and it just such a nice
message and so I've just been liking it
and then um that's really it that really
hasn't been some new music and it's kind
of I need some good stuff me too summers
is making an announcement on Thursday
and and I really think it's a new single
and summer's coming so that's when all
the good music comes now we have a lot
of viewer question Omar's album oh yeah
that's the stuff that's the stuff we
have a lot of viewer questions for you
that I'm going to get to but before I
see interesting to me but before I do
have you heard about 23andme if you
haven't like you're living under a rock
and you this is your first time watching
the show so welcome with twenty three
Emmys health and an trusty ancestry
service kit you can explore 125 plus
personalized genetic reports that may
reveal the link between your DNA and
your health traits and more including
your chances of developing certain
diseases I was just watching a
documentary about a woman who was trying
to do this and instead she just extorted
all of Silicon Valley green know it was
the inventor so why don't we stick with
23andme because they're getting real
results you know without the fraud
diabetes is a growing public health
challenge one in three adults in the
United States has pre-diabetes but 90%
of those with pre-diabetes don't know
that they have it with 23andme who find
out these things about yourself and
address them before they become a bigger
issues in your life order to your
23andme health and ancestry service kid
at 23andme comm slash toast that's the
number two three AMD me.com slash toast
again that's 23andme comm slash toes I
used it 23andme comm slash toast did you
yeah I still haven't sent in my thing
some kind of scared but um I'm scared to
find out that you're not my real
yeah what happened I don't know I feel
like I'm obviously they have all of
these Jeanette and health and genetic
kits that you can do and you learn so
much about yourself like why you're
always tired you should do it for that
really and they also tell you like what
are you like savory or sweet I think
that's a also tell you what's the time
that you should wait like that they tell
you what time you naturally wake up
so like months ago 2 p.m. right but
maybe there's a time in there that's
actually like maybe it's like 9:30 and
so maybe you just need like 30 more
minutes of sleep and we all feel good so
you should definitely try it out and
then also to confirm that you are my
sister and my counselor wonder if they
do counts for testing like is this your
real counselor she is that she is not
the counselor okay speaking of the
counselor it is time for questions for
the snitch so interesting that people
have questions clearly everybody like
just knows everything about my life you
know yeah but I feel like we see so much
of your life and then it's the question
is how does she do it all because as
much as you're a snitch and like you
just rest on your laurels you're
actually working pretty hard these days
and like you're traveling a lot and
you're very busy so how do you manage
all of it what is your priority in terms
of school tour snitcher ii and all the
other things that you do what they like
I don't know like obviously school would
come first because I would really really
like to graduate like I'm not I'm not
trying to fail and stay another semester
so I guess school and just getting
things done and then tour how do I do it
well here's the thing everyone's always
like high school oh I don't know about
you guys but like college like classes
are huge your teachers don't really know
if you show up or not all you have hair
I can't imagine that's good for the
throw all you have to do is like do your
assignments be there for your test and
it's on you to make up like the work and
like make up what you missed and stuff
like that so obviously it's not ideal
but like nobody really cares that I'm
not there as sad as that is
but on top of that when some of my
classes are smaller like Oh like you
just talk to your teachers it's like hey
like this is where I'm at specifically
at NYU like a lot of people really do
have jobs and like that's like kind of
how things like work there that like
they're like people who are like
actresses and like whatever so it's like
they're very understanding and you just
talk to them and they're like okay like
cool and like if you need to extra
credit they'll give you extra credit
like that's it it's really just like it
you just have to be on top of it but
like there's no like secret you know
what I mean it's just like I don't show
up to a lot of classes and like that
stuff's and it gives me like terrible
anxiety but I have friends in all my
classes so like if I miss something
important they will tell me and I'm home
like I'm home when I have like a test
and this and that but I do all my
assignments I do everything and I'm just
like it's a lot but I'm just like on top
of it and like just like keep it
together
I guess so you're graduating this spring
hallelujah praise the Lord how I sent
her her Google Calendar invite for it on
London then I forgot that her graduating
means that there's a graduation ceremony
that I'm supposed to attend and I don't
know what it is maybe I had a traumatic
experience my childhood at a graduation
but I hate graduation ceremonies I hate
them so be glad I'm gonna Yankee Stadium
I don't want to go to yours I don't want
to go to mine I think they're so boring
and such a waste of time and everyone
has to get their name called like a big
[ __ ] baby and it's like the gift is
the graduation I couldn't ignore is the
diploma you know it's so crazy I could
not agree more I think they're so
annoying like so just like drawing out
whatever from the school that I'm in at
NYU they're doing it twice that day you
choose you want the 10 a.m. or the 3
p.m. I obviously chose a 3 p.m. for
everybody's sake but like they do it
twice just like you know like the Dean
like makes his speech twice they call
out the names twice it's like really you
once isn't enough but then that's not
even it then there's like the whole NYU
won't much as I Yankee Stadium which I
will obviously not be attending but be
glad that I'm not making you go to that
I'm just making you go to like two hours
and then I'm going and then a good
dinner yeah and I have to plan the rager
oh yeah you have to plan they haven't
planning a lot of stuff right now
parties wise to maybe I'll just like add
it to my docket of party yeah just do
that so you are graduating in the spring
and like maybe that makes it easy if you
were a sophomore you want to be able to
be so flexible right now with your
schedule like what but I know that's the
thing if I was like a fresh
Minoru sophomore I don't think I'd be
able to do this a lot of like those
classes are just like like harder
whatever but I really am a second
semester senior and so like things are
just more relaxed like like my
assignment I really honestly haven't
really had that many time it's they're
mostly just like final papers that like
will hit me in May right so as long as
you do those papers you graduate so what
would you have to not do in order to
like really have all of this hinder your
graduation like what would you have to
miss or not I guess like miss just like
me like you just but if I just didn't do
anything
I can't submit my assignments didn't
submit my papers didn't show up for
tests with just like all three or things
I would never do mm-hmm so do you get
stressed oh my god do you know me yeah
how do you handle it
I cook about it a lot
oh I know so that's how I in what I just
talked about it like how I'm so stressed
and I need people to like just like talk
me talk me down and be like listen it's
really not that big of a deal and it's
like oh yeah that's right yeah that is
always helpful okay we'll get back to
school what's not I can't wait until
like we don't want to ask you those
questions um tour what is something that
Claudia does on tour that annoys you the
most I have such a good answer for this
after every single show she literally
thinks she did terribly and she does
amazing and it's so annoying and it's
like she doesn't listen when I said I'm
like honestly was so so great like we're
worried we were just in Phoenix and she
had done a show that I was that I've
seen the show Hunter tribes all her
shows are great honestly they're amazing
but she had gentleman that was like
incredible and I got off and I was like
that was the best it ever went and she
was like what and I was like you didn't
think sound she was like no not at all
like that's what bothers me just like
she doesn't know how good she is which
is such a like nice answer but it's
annoying yeah cuz then you always have
to like have to be like always coming up
like knows great it's great it's like I
shouldn't tell you this right and then
you found if you're always saying was
great it was great like she thinks I'm
just like a what's it called a yes-man
yeah that's not it I would tell her when
it's what it's not good yeah so with all
of this traveling and work and school it
hasn't been hard to stay body by snitch
oh my god it's been very very difficult
I'm not gonna lie it's just so hard to
be good when you're on the road and
especially like in airports and all that
stuff it's just like so hard to make
like good decisions I don't know I don't
like there are times when I like think
I've like oh my god
gained so much weight like nobody's
telling me like I get so paranoid and in
my head but then it's like I got home
and it's like I'm fine so it's just like
I mean Claudia really try not to indulge
so much so like builds like once in a
while but we really never finish our
meal so it's like we'll get like the
brownie at the comedy show but we'll
each have a bite and like that's really
it because it's not that good but like
so when I'm i snacking is what kind of
gets me it's like you know the mini bar
I can have some pretzels and this and
that but like when we go to when we go
to like have a meal I always just like
try and be conscious and like get a
salad with like a protein in that but it
really is very very difficult I can't
even like I can't even trust that enough
like when I was in Florida but that's an
account that was vacation I ate like an
animal and like whatever you know like
you have to do you just have to do that
and it's like four-year and it's like
it's so hard on yourself because it's
like eventually you will be back home
you will be back on track you will be
back on a routine so it's just like let
it happen well might I make a suggestion
to help you keep your weight loss on
track yeah I'd love some have you heard
of noon no okay noon is something that I
love and like I love tracking my
progression like in anything that I do
that's why I like I'm obsessed with
having a planner I just need to know
where you been I need to be able to see
my life visually including my weight and
sticking to a weight loss plan can be
hard especially when you don't know how
to handle the thoughts and obstacles
that hold you back from making progress
and especially when you're the
production assistant on the dirty jeans
tour not even on the producer most
people who lose weight gain all back why
because most weight loss plans just tell
you what to do while you're on the plan
not actor not how to live with it not
how to tour with it with new mule lose
the guilt and learn how to develop a new
relationship with food try something
different try new different results call
for a different approach learn don't
diet so for me I want to just I always
want to lose five pounds I feel like
packing Regina George but also always
I've been wanting to change my muscle
makeup my percentage of that so it's
like the weight on the scale won't
necessarily change but I'll look
different because what my body's made up
will change and so Noom has helped me do
that by keeping track of like what I'm
eating when I'm working out and helping
me the tips about how to change what I'm
eating to you know really hone it and I
mean I'm not perfect all the time I'm
not perfect most of the time but it
helps me know what I need to do in order
to achieve my goals yeah numa's designed
for result
it's out with the old habits in with the
new sign up for your trial today at noon
and oom calm / toast what do you have to
lose lol visit noon calm sized toasts to
start your trial today
again that's Noom calm / - toasts start
losing weight for good I feel like
sometimes when I do these reads I
started to sound like American camper
it's so excited about the thing that I'm
talking about you do like what do i what
do you have to lose what you have to
lose counselor snitch trying him today
yeah totally
speaking of counselor snitch campus
coming up I literally are you freaking
out are you I am I feel like it's so
much pressure because I'm gonna have to
be like in character the whole time no
because I'm gonna be freaking out like
remember during camp toast one when I
just couldn't stop calling you counselor
say that's how it started that's how it
started and now now that I'm Emmett
staking out a life of its own
like how many cameras are gonna come out
it's like there's just gonna be like
clones of you totally but it's like I'm
only one me so I just need a bunch of
different hats literate literally
speaking of how's mrs. hat she's good
you know she's switching her hats all
the time she's switching hats all the
time okay a lot of people did ask about
your dating life and I just I I hate to
do it to you but I don't want to ignore
men so we set you up on hinge on a
patron episode last month have you used
it at all um like not really I mean it
wouldn't when we start with like
initially I like thought it was like a
fun thing to do so I'd like I want it
with my friends make a video game sort
of yeah literally and then I kind of
just stopped especially like I'm never
really here so like what's really the
point I just go on one date nothing came
of it so just to quench everyone's
thirst because I was like did she go the
I went okay it was like nine you know it
wasn't bad but yeah dating life just
like you're a busy woman it's very hard
to date someone who's always on the road
no we'll see the summer ones like I'm
actually back here and like settle down
and all that stuff and like everyone
graduates and yeah bro comes back to the
city yeah like give a tan yelling you're
look really not that worried I'm not
that worried either but like it's just
fun to live vicariously through a snitch
okay
yeah a lot of dating questions and there
was one question that we got more than
anything really I'm nervous
Oh what do I pata or this camera god I
thought it was nobody do you I was like
oh god no I would never do that but
seriously what do I pack for this camp
okay
bum bum bum bum bum what she packed with
scamp honestly lots of shorts lots of
sneakers teen top's sports bras you know
activewear and then some my cute stuff
jean shorts like cute top you know crop
top central it'll be hot maybe some cute
sandals don't really pack heels that's
not necessary
hats hats are helpful you don't want to
burn your head and you want to be mrs.
hat or mister yep sunscreen bathing
suits you know get that tan on that goes
pretty good packing list cancer stage
where do you like to shop Oh interesting
I like to shop online I hate shopping in
store right like just hate it um big
like boohoo revolve trend savvy you know
I love me some trends out yes a so it's
just like stuff like that that as I cute
like sex and stuff like that yeah there
I'm not like it I don't shop anywhere
crazy like where do you like to shop ooh
it's hard because I just like shop where
I see something cute yeah I shop where I
am you know like first of all just shop
anywhere like anytime yes there's a
problem yeah like I could be in any city
like I'll be online and I'll see
something like I'll just buy I'm not
like a brand like more like store
specific worth like it's there and um
also sometimes I'll be looking for
something specific and it's like type
into Google what I want know just like
see where it is Jun yang totally okay
this is a hard question for me but
what's your least favorite nickname that
I had this teens have force on you um
probably tied snitch monster because
that makes you monster and it's just
like so long it makes no sense and it's
not English okay well we don't call you
it that much well nobody calls me it
anymore I like to mark you Sharky oh
that's cute they call me that when I was
like 10 what has been your favorite City
you have toured with Claudia
Huntsville Alabama ah that was so fun
okay leave it to me though um least
favorite city would be I know Claudia
says Cleveland mm-hmm you can't say that
in front of me
oh she didn't she say it in front of you
yeah but like you're not gonna do that
to me also right least favorite city
hmm oh um buffalo sorry okay that's
there it's cold there and it was just
like dull I'm sure you think it's like
see the sights and have the Wild Wings
and go to a Bills game that's also by
the way really a problem like I wish it
I could have eat like uncle Sherm eat so
I could really you know try the ladies
of the land in other cities I get what a
burger like I do get the taquito with
them with the hash brown potatoes
instead of like me or whatever like I
would love to get like a freaking burger
you know or chicken tenders but honestly
body icing is just happy that I can't
but my heart's not what is the hardest
part about being a tour manager for
Claud hardest part about being a tourist
she a difficult boss like yeah the Devil
Wears Prada situation over there not at
all it's weird how how well we get along
like we have honestly like really never
fought knock on wood we like don't get
annoyed with each other which is really
nice the hardest part I would just say
is like the waking up early in the
flight so sometimes I have to wake up at
3:00 a.m.
like to make a 6:00 a.m. flight like dad
is just freaking torture oh you know
it's also the worst part that Claudia
flies first and I fly coach except she
did find me home from Arizona first and
it was so nice of her but you're getting
so many miles so many more that's free
flights for you yeah look at the to go
away with your friend like that's how I
actually don't even have I paid for my
bike but you're like eventually
eventually doing that so no it's great
miles wise but just like on my book I
would just say the hardest part is just
like it's very tough on me well you're
[ __ ] on myself very clear but I'm happy
doing it and it's fun and it's like I'll
never be able to do it again it's like
such a cool thing to be doing anyway
totally like to see the whole kind of
you like what I was right when I'm at
interviews for jobs everyone's like I
can't leave you're like 21 just like a
producer of a comedy child I'm just like
me neither but that's it's so crazy
because you really you're such a snitch
but you're really working so hard and
for those of you who are still wondering
what to pack for this camp might I
suggest checking out thredUP
imagine diving into the biggest closet
in the world pack with your favorite
brands and style
unbelievable prices did you know fashion
is the second most polluting industry in
the world that's why we love shopping
secondhand at threat up choosing news
clothes gives clothes a second life and
keeps one less item from ending up in
the trash thread up is the world's
largest online consignment and thrift
store with up to 90% off estimated
retail prices they have such great
brands everything from made well
anthropology to higher end brands like
Coach you can be the Selena Gomez you
wish to see in the world everything is
hand inspected and triple check to
ensure it's in its high quality
condition honestly this is a great place
to shop or camp dose like first of all
it's just such sustainable fashion yeah
I love a good deal and you can like get
super cute things that would be so much
more and also like not feel bad about
like wearing them sweating in them etc
honestly I'm gonna check it out cuz I
want some cute clothes for stagecoach
woo that's as you could call so you
should visit thread up calm Sasha toast
today for an extra 30 percent off your
first order
that's thre DUP comm slash toast for 30%
off your first order no a in there
Cerreta up comm slash toast for an extra
30% off today terms a play I need to do
so much shopping this episode has
reminded me even when I was getting
dressed today with like my new shoes I
was like okay have new shoes but I don't
have anything else you know Oh totally
yeah me too I need like shirts blouses
like I need shirts me too we have such a
fine good like airport like clothing
ever look so cute in the airport now you
look like such a slob and it's like I
feel like I need to do better especially
like yeah they want to get first-class
upgrades like oh yeah you're being one
of those but she always gets upgraded
and I never get upgraded she has such a
higher modality in the mean it's not
there well you're working on it I know
but it's not don't beat yourself up over
it it's always like number one on the
upgrade list and I'm always like 36 like
you see like CEO and then you see mo
like literally here that's so sad
anywhere work your way up I'm working
I'm working my way like when I was 21 I
wasn't even on the upgrade list so I'm a
yeah I'm thinking
36 I think just by saying like put me on
it that's all you have to do understood
well thank you for joining us we have to
go pick up our nephews me chest fur and
and yeah that's my dating life totally
England he said
man other than my husband he's the best
man in the world where thank you for
joining us where can everyone follow you
who don't already because they're not in
tune or this is their first time
watching in which case this is our
little sister my sister we call her the
snitch we have a patreon episode on why
she also councillor snitch counsel you
got a snitch as she has a total
international harem of campers she's an
international is expanding every day
she's an international counsellor of
mystery you gonna follow me at Marcus
ray and you can also follow me at body
but snitch even though she's kind of
dormant right now but she'll come back
eventually just that is incredibly hard
to do on the road yeah
she'll yeah she'll be back I feel like
summer is gonna be summers gonna be and
like just like give her time like she's
she's getting back into a routine and
figuring herself out but she's still
here she thinks about her all the time
yeah okay cool well thank you so much
for being here and helping your sister
out to do such a fun episode for me
because like these guys to host a week
of Jack do take over and it's really fun
and like it forces me like you know to
really hone my craft but sometimes it's
nice just to kick back with the sister
like I usually do everyday yes and just
throw another sister in the mix so Thank
You counselor snitch we love you for
having me just on the garlic bread
snitch ass on the garlic bread